bon sang le jeudi 10 septembre merci de
nous retrouver pour ce nouveau journal
d'information comment se fit avec les
titres de votre actualité locale
transport en cette rentrée deux
nouvelles lignes de bus se mettent en
place des changements également
annonciateur du nouveau visage de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines une agglomération élargie au
1er janvier 2016 dans ce journal nous
parlerons également des chantiers à
venir de la ligne 18 du grand paris aux
travaux d'aménagement autour de la gare
de la verrière
ils viennent des quatre coins du monde
des étudiants passeront un semestre
voire une année complète à l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
pourquoi ce choix et comment se passe
l'accueil nous le verrons tout à l'heure
enfin 6e édition de sentez vous sport ce
week-end opération nationale pour
sensibiliser le grand public à la
pratique d'une activité physique une
loisirs y participe à nouveau son
responsable événementiel sera avec nous
tout à l'heure et dans l'actualité
d'aujourd'hui nous revenons sur
l'arrivée des 78 réfugiés syriens et
irakiens
hier dans les yvelines à bonnel partie
de munich en allemagne
ils ont été prises en charge par la
préfecture l'association habitat et
humanisme et la croix rouge
ils sont accueillis dans la paroisse
dorante où ils seront logés pendant un
mois selon nos dernières informations
ils ont commencé des démarches pour
passer du statut de migrant à réfugiés
des démarches simplifiées par la
préfecture qui envoyait du personnel
administratif auprès d'eux du côté de la
mairie de beaune l on s'organise pour
récolter des vêtements et faire appel à
la générosité des habitants
le secours populaire français qui
s'occupe également de l'accueil de ces
migrants partout en france appelle
également aux dons pour venir en aide
aux familles qui ont souvent tout perdu
plus d'informations sur le site
www.solarimpulse.com r mais tout d'abord
bonne part les transports dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour en parler avec mon plateau
maïs floret
l'histoire vous êtes responsables de
services nouveaux usages à des mobilités
de la casse qui alors tout d'abord je
vais demander quelles sont les
nouveautés de cette rentrée au niveau
transports dans l'agglomération au
niveau transport les nouveautés c'est de
l'offre bus en plus en fait
la rentrée c'est de ligne une ligne qui
vient de plaisir grignon l'a50 qui est
une simplification des lignes existantes
et surtout une nouvelle offre la 51e qui
permet de relier saint quentin au centre
commercial le ch est né à l'hôpital
mignot donc ça va faciliter le transport
des usagers saint quentinois cette ligne
intérieure ou bnc ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle les lignes intérieures open
c'est-à-dire qu'elles vont hors de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
en tout cas pour celles de versailles ce
que du côté de la cité stibus il ya
aussi du changement du côté de ski bus
et il n'y a pas de changement d'offre
pour la rentrée de septembre il y en
aura encore de l'année les enjeux phares
de cette rentrée c'est les transports ce
qu'il y a des nouveaux changements il ya
de nouveaux chantiers qui vont être
qu'ils sont en train d'être fait c'est
vraiment à l'enjeu voilà deux de cette
rentrée pour à saint quentin en yvelines
alors au niveau des transports
effectivement il ya des chantiers en
cours enfin en tout cas qui nous un
paquet le chantier de la rd 30 au niveau
de plaisir qui va améliorer à terme la
circulation sur l'agglomération au
niveau de la rentrée on est surtout sur
de l'information sur les transports sur
la mise à jour de tous les supports et
la préparation la semaine de la mobilité
parce qu'en fait on sait qu'à la rentrée
c'est une période de changement de
comportement et donc de faire en sorte
que les gens et la bonne information
pour préparer leur déplacement
et justement la rentrée vous parlez de
nouveaux comportements est ce que vous
essayez d amener les habitants vers des
pratiques plus vertes on va dire plus
écolo peut-être favoriser le vélo ou je
ne sais pas le covoiturage alors on a
plusieurs actions sur saint quentin sur
ça alors sur le vélo aujourd'hui c'est
déjà ça apporter de l'information parce
qu'on en a sorti le la carte des
itinéraires cyclables qui devait être
mise à jour qui a été mise à jour donc
ça c'est pour préparer son itinéraire
vélo sur le covoiturage à cela ça par
exemple on va sur le site internet garde
tous les documents sont en ligne sur
site internet de l'agglomération ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'on a aussi un
lieu qui est à la gare de saint quentin
en yvelines qui s'appelle la jante à
mobilité ou là vous avez aussi les
supports papiers parce qu'il ya encore
des gens qui préfèrent les supports
papier donc vous avez le choix tout est
en ligne sur le site internet de
l'agglomération dans la rubrique se
déplacer ou sinon si vous préférez il ya
aussi la chance de mobilité en gare de
saint quentin en yvelines
est-ce que les chances parents sont
balisés pour les gens qui
ray avant leur trajet mais qui n'ont pas
le sens de l'orientation bah c'est en
fait c'est l'intérêt de l'agent sa
mobilité c'est vous avez des gens en
face de vous qui vont vous aider à
préparer votre déplacement
après en terme de transports il ya des
applications comme via navigo en
ile-de-france qui vous permet de
connaître tous les horaires de bus des
trains pour préparer au mieux le
déplacement donc c'est chacun sa
technologie chacun sont deux modes pour
préparer son déplacement et en termes de
covoiturage peut-être des nouvelles
actions est ce qu'il ya beaucoup de
covoiturage qui est fait à saint quentin
en yvelines alors sur covoiturage on est
toujours avec l'application waze up qui
se développe beaucoup dans les
entreprises de saint quentin en yvelines
au crédit agricole au technocentre la
snecma en fait l'intérêt c'est que ça
permet d'atteindre une masse de
covoitureurs de plus en plus important
et donc de trouver plus facilement la
bonne personne pour ça votre trajet
c'est prévu de mettre l'accent a
justement peut-être sur voyez ça peut
encore plus cette année
alors là notamment la semaine prochaine
on est en entreprise donc là il ya des
interventions de rise up qui vient
présenter l'application de salariés en
discuter en direct
donc on va continuer à parler de
covoiturage parce qu'on pense que c'est
une solution pour se déplacer un peu
mieux et de façon un peu plus
écologiques en voiture beaucoup de
choses vont changer en 2016 pas ce qui
est arrivé de nouvelles communes dans la
communauté d'agglomération est-ce que
voilà justement ces lignes de bus va y
avoir plus de choses qui vont être
faites pour désenclaver en tout cas
offert que les communes comme les
clayes-sous-bois où nos repas soient
plus facilement relier par exemple à
montigny-le-bretonneux
alors effectivement on va continuer à
travailler sur l'offre de bus pour
l'améliorer liaison du nouveau
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
pour autant on travaille on continue à
travailler sur le territoire de saint
quentin tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
puisque dans l'année on va essayer on va
avoir des renforts d'offres sur par
exemple à 415 qui est la ligne
notre ligne la plus importante qui va de
bois d'arcy qui passe par 150 ans et qui
fait toutes les gares de l'agglomération
donc il va garder des renforts d'offres
pour améliorer le service
et puis là 439 qui va se refaire ça y
aussi eogn et vous a plu se voit là des
trains est ce qu'il ya peut-être des
discussions qui sont bien passés avec le
stif ou la sncf pour d'être amélioré à
cette desserte
alors sur le train où ça fait on discute
beaucoup sur le ferroviaire
ce qui ressort c'est que le ferroviaire
c'est peut-être un peu long à mettre en
oeuvre ce fait un moment qu'on discute
on a réussi à avoir plus de trains sur
la ligne lui la ligne la défense et on
continue à travailler à échanger pour
travailler sur la ligne montparnasse on
aimerait idéalement qui est plus de
train et on n'oublie jamais la question
des ter centre et les points noirs un
petit peu faim si on peut dire les
points noirs les points ont fait qui
reste à améliorer justement en termes de
transport quels sont les retours vous
que vous avez vite voilà ça c'est notre
le tiff pour 2016-2017 travaille
vraiment sur ces points alors le il ya
deux points sur les transports c'est le
fait qu'on puisse
passé en gros d'elancourt trappe plus
facilement et guyancourt montini qu'on
puisse traverser et ça c'est vrai aussi
bien pour les voitures parce qu'on avait
problèmes de congestion mais aussi des
bus puis traverser quand mauvais l'on
puisse traverser donc ça en a pas mal de
projets sur ces questions là et c'est
d'autant plus importante avec la
perspective de la grande agglomération
puisque on pourra les plaisirs aux côtés
du côté de montigny qui encourt aussi
directement et d'ailleurs je le rappelle
vous en parlais tout à l'heure à partir
de lundi prochain où débute la semaine
de la mobilité européenne
il va y avoir donc des initiatives
prévues toute cette semaine c'est ça du
lundi au vendredi en entreprise monsieur
niveau des particuliers les habitants
oui on a deux types d'opérations cette
année en fait on à la semaine prochaine
les opérations auprès des salariés en
entreprise sur l'heure du déjeuner et la
semaine du 24 25 septembre des
opérations
sur les zones d'activités mais pour
découvrir le territoire donc ils seront
ouvertes à tous pour se balader une
espèce de chasse au trésor autour des
déplacements et bien donc voilà des des
initiatives qui seront mis en place sur
deux semaines merci beaucoup mais il
ferait d'être venu et d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
nous en parlions dans l'édition du
journal de mercredi le boulevard schuler
va être modifié un doublement des voies
est prévue pour 2017
hier une réunion publique se tenait en
mairie de maurepas pour donner la parole
aux citoyens
retour sur ce projet il relie maurepas à
la verrière sur la nationale 10 le
boulevard schueller et pour bon nombre
de ses usagers
synonyme de difficultés alors le projet
de réaménagement intéresse des habitants
des représentants associatifs souvenu se
renseigner c'est pas une surprise ça
fait très longtemps qu est dans les
cartons donc voilà donc voir un petit
peu l'impact un peu et puis comment ça
ça va s'organiser quand on veut que ce
pont soif effectivement de façon à
rendre la vie plus facile
le projet de doublement et raccordement
dupont vise à désengorger le trafic
améliorer l'efficacité des bus et
l'accessibilité aux gars estimé à 11
millions trois cent cinquante mille
euros
il est financé par l'état la région et
le département l'agglomération participe
à hauteur de 1 million neuf cent
cinquante six mille euros et pour la
mairie de maurepas l'enveloppent s'élève
à 834 1000 euros les problèmes
financiers
ne sont pas véritablement un enjeu parce
que c'était négocié depuis un moment
mais nous avons quand même réussi à
abaisser l'enveloppent grâce à des
financements supplémentaires
un investissement qui va de pair avec la
volonté de développer les transports un
enjeu phare pour l'agglomération
on est dans cette dynamique là d'essayer
d'avoir des pôles gare attractif
on a commencé avec le pôle gare de
montigny on continue avec le pôle gare
de la verrière
mais là ça va quand même un petit peu
plus loin puisque aujourd'hui célèbre
dupont schuller qui va permettre d'avoir
athènes accès à la gare où toute
sécurité et surtout dans des temps
record le doublement du pont schuller
première étape d'un grand projet urbain
qui concerne l'ensemble du secteur gare
bécane le chantier devrait commencer en
2010 est pour finir fin 2018
et c'est une grande nouveauté l'avant
projet de la tangentielle ouest a été
validé le 8 juillet dernier par le stif
l'objectif est de réhabiliter la grande
ceinture afin de relier toutes les
grandes villes de l'ouest parisien
le projet financé principalement par la
région le stif le département des
yvelines à hauteur de 300 millions
d'euros
les travaux devraient débuter en
septembre prochain regardez ce reportage
de fanny bourdillon la tg au
tangentielle ouest
un grand projet de tram-train qui
donnera un tout autre visage à la grande
ceinture ouest
le stif syndicat des transports a validé
cet été l'avant projet les travaux
devraient donc débuter en septembre 2016
mais pour certains élus il y a déjà eu
trop de retard j'espère qu'on va pas
continuer à accumuler du retard et que
tous les grands engagements qui ont été
pris vont être tenues il y a des projets
que des villes et le long du tracé de la
tg haut en termes de développement
économique en termes d'habitat et il est
important que cette ligne où le plus
rapidement possible
les financements sont maintenant réunies
le coût total des travaux s'élève à 300
millions d'euros
il se divise en deux phases la phase une
prolongera la ligne aile déjà existantes
afin de rejoindre le rer a de
saint-germain-en-laye et au sud le rer c
de saint cyr la phase 2 raccordera
attend
l'ancien l'ouest à la ville d'achères un
tracé qui devrait donc réduire la
circulation automobile avec la
tangentielle ouest vous avez cette
relation qui est fait non pas de ville
vers le centre de paris mais en
périphérie d'une manière circulaire
autour de paris c'est comme un
périphérique mais pas pour la voiture
pour la voie de chemin de fer l'objectif
est de permettre aux franciliens de
gagner du temps pour se déplacer de
banlieue à banlieue notamment au sein
des yvelines en exemple de saint cyr
saint cyr pour aller à saint germain ce
sera 20 minutes de trajet comme le
trajet avec une ligne ouvert très
largement de 6h à minuit en principe
avec un train un tram train toutes les
cinq minutes d'un jour de moins
la tangentielle ouest devrait être mise
en service en 2020 travaux toujours en
juin dernier voisins le bretonneux
découvre le tracé de la ligne 18 passant
par sa commune pro baleine il concerne
un quartier résidentiel et le sol dans
lesquelles les travaux doivent être
faits et argileux et la ville n'avait
jamais été concertés la maire de la
commune alexandra rosetti a été reçu par
la société grand paris toujours au mois
juin les précisions de mélanie poker
c'est parce que la ligne 18 doit passer
sous ce quartier celui de la bretonnière
que voisins le bretonneux est monté au
créneau
la commune souhaite un nouveau tracé il
ya forcément un frein certes alternative
puisqu'on a le golf à côté on a des
endroits où il n'y a pas d'habitations
l'idée n'étant pas de renvoyer aux
autres que je ne veux pas avoir un mais
l'idée étant de trouver je dirais une
solution qui convienne à tous
et donc je pense qu'on devrait arriver à
trouver un accord pour l'envisager l'élu
a rencontré la société grand paris en
charge du projet le but d'un futur tracé
éviter ce quartier où une quarantaine de
maisons sont concernées construite sur
un sol argileux nous constituons un
dossier avec toutes les maisons qui ont
dû être renforcés parce que c'est quand
même ça le plus gros souci c'est qu'il
ya beaucoup de maisons où il ya des
micropieux à 15 20 m de profondeur et
donc forcément les gens sont inquiets et
c'est logique sur le devenir de leur
maison si on creuse en dessous d'ici
deux mois la commune connaîtra les
résultats des sondages des sols réalisés
dans le quartier la société du grand
paris elle a lancé des études pour un
autre tracé est toujours à voisins le
bretonneux après une phase de test
débutée en septembre 2014
le conseil départemental la casse qui
est la commune de voisins-le-bretonneux
ont lancé les travaux de la route
départementale 36 et la route
départementale 14 à voisins le
bretonneux
le 24 août dernier dans le sens trappe
de voies de circulation étaient mises en
place en direction de château fort des
îlots végétalisée sont créés les
aménagements sont prévus pour fluidifier
la circulation on écoute la mer
alexandra rosetti l'idée l'était de
fluidifier la traversée de voisins et ça
ça fonctionne on a gagné en minute pour
pour traverser voisin matin en
particulier
et puis en passant en fait ce carrefour
passe à trois phases de feu au lieu de
quatre donc forcément il ya un gain de
temps après ça génère forcément autour
du de l'îlot central
ça génère un petit peu de conflits mais
je pense que globalement c'est assez
satisfaisant et ses routes
départementales vous pourrez peut-être
les emprunter avec cette voiture
la ford gt40 2016 mais ce n'est pas pour
tout de suite il faudra attendre
aujourd'hui le jeudi 10 septembre le
campus de l'estac a étudié ford pour la
présentation en avant première de cette
sportive
dévoilé en début d'année au salon de
détroit aux états unis la nouvelle ford
gt sera commercialisé
mondiale courant 2016 année du
cinquantenaire de la victoire de ford
aux 24 heures du mans
pas de v8 pour ce beau denis tu mets le
plus puissant moteur ecoboost jamais
conçu par fort d'une belle
avant-première ou un avant goût pour la
journée automobile plein phare sur
l'auto prévu à montigny le bretonneux ce
dimanche
enfin la verrière le gymnase devrait
bientôt réouvrir ses portes situées au
bois de l'étang le bâtiment datait de
1976 et a donc été totalement réhabilité
durant un an avec mise aux normes et
agrandissement des salles les travaux
ont été financés par la ville avec
l'aide de l'état ait de la casse qui
pour un montant d'un peu plus de 1
million et demi d'euros
des aménagements resteront à faire
notamment pour les salles de boxe de
danse et de musculation
l'inauguration est prévue courant
novembre et sachez le la rentrée n'a pas
commencé pour tout le monde les
étudiants étrangers de l'ue vs qu sont
arrivées cette semaine sur le campus de
saint quentin en yvelines issus de onze
nationalités différentes ils suivent
jusqu'à lundi leur stage de pré rentrée
pour un séminaire ayant tous déjà de
bonnes bases en français ils viennent
apprendre l'histoire l'informatique ou
le droit fanni bourdillon les a
rencontrés je n'aime pas on n'a pas eu
de veine dans la poule 5
je m'appelle claire et je viens de lire
en blatter
je me souviens juste
maroc états unis hongrie les 70
étudiants étrangers de l'ue vs qu
viennent des quatre coins du monde
ils ont posé leurs valises à saint
quentin en yvelines pour un semestre de
6 mois ou une année entière en cette
rentrée l'association étudiante
fraîchement up est là pour les aiguiller
là le but d'intégrer les étudiants
étrangers de les faire enfin années mais
leur séjour en france et également de
promouvoir les changes
french maroc organise des visites de
campus présente les cours prépare des
repas de bienvenue
tout est fait pour que les étudiants se
repère rapidement dans l'université et
les premières impressions sont plutôt
positives et sceller les campus sont
très bien équipées des ressources sont
disponibles blé les procédés le
personnel est toujours disponible de
répondre à tous nos questions avant
d'attaquer les cours la semaine
prochaine les étudiants doivent passer
par la case administration une étape en
bois centre en a beaucoup à faire les
documents de remplir et donc lui
maintenant je suis un petit peu stressé
mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
dans le même cas que moi donc je suis
pas seul oui je suis un peu stressé
parce qu'il faut faire beaucoup des
documents importants
après beaucoup de documents et
l'administration de la france est très
compliqué pour parfaire leur intégration
les étudiants vous recevoir des cours de
français afin de profiter pleinement de
leur année universitaire et nous
parlerons sport avec les rendez vous du
week end en un instant avec vous wilfrid
mais bien sûr le week-end approche à
grands pas et il faut savoir que samedi
la ville de voisins-le-bretonneux
organise son forum des associations au
gymnase des pyramides deux voisins le
bretonneux pour en parler avec nous en
plateau pascal pieds-noirs bonsoir
bonsoir il est directeur du centre
alfred de vigny merci d'être venu sur
notre plateau alors vous serez présent
samedi il me semble que vous avez
beaucoup occupé une grande place
justement dans le gymnase pour le forum
des associations oui il faut dire déjà
que la ville de voisins à voit les
choses en grand puisque à l'événementiel
qui est qui reçoit le forum avec même
une extension sur l'eau les sur la salle
delande est effectivement le stand f3
celui du centre alfred de vigny ses
douze mètres de stands une vingtaine
d'intervenants pour essayer de mieux
répondre d'informer les habitants sur ce
que produit le centre alfred de vigny
bien sûr alors justement qu'elles sont
un peu les nouveautés proposées seront
très belles nouveautés je vais avoir du
mal à citer toutes les activités où on
peut parler des nouveautés le catalogue
d'activités c'est un peu plus de 50
activités sur le centre donc
effectivement on essaye chaque année de
se renouveler
cette année on aura de la une formation
sur la création de sites internet c'est
nouveau on aura également de l'angle de
l'allemand on avait beaucoup de mal à
faire des cours d'allemand organiser des
cours d'allemand ça va revenir
ça va venir supporter nos cours
d'italien de chinois et oui d'espagnol
d'anglais d' american business enfin
voilà une forte activité linguistique et
bien sûr toutes les activités manuelles
et artistiques que peut développer un
centre socioculturel alors s'il ya des
choses insolites stupre et nous
conseiller alors oui en ponctuelle on va
parce qu'on travaille déjà sur les
activités ponctuelles et notamment pour
les vacances de toussaint on va
s'orienter plutôt sur la jeunesse et on
va créer un stage de relooking donc avec
maquilleuse et puis un studio photo pour
faire des photos de bouc pour les jeunes
voilà c'est quelque chose de nouveau est
assez original vous attendez combien de
personnes samedi au forum alors
plusieurs milliers faut savoir que pour
nous cette journée c'est c'est une
journée très importante pour le secteur
associatif un secteur associatif qui est
important sur voisins plus d'une
centaine d'associations faut dire que le
centre groupe à peu près 2000 adhérents
et on va faire à peu près je dirais un
bon tiers d'inscription donc oui c'est
une grosse journée et une belle journée
une belle journée et justement la vie
associative à voisins le bretonneux
musique et ça elle se portait plutôt
bien
pourtant on est en période de
restriction budgétaire est ce que ça
vous impact vous alors oui bien sûr on a
des tassements budget surtout sur le
budget des familles intéressées c'est
pas nouveau voisin bien sûr est concerné
ce que le constate sur le centre c'est
qu'un tassement et c'est surtout sur le
nombre d'activités pratiquées et
l'enfance et préserver quand même
l'ensemble du loisir en france
et préservé mais on voit bien que les
parents de regard d'un petit peu sur
leurs propres loisirs et au niveau de la
mairesse qui a des activités doivent se
disent pas parce qu'il a plus assez de
financement à ma connaissance non par
contre nous gestionnaire puisqu'un
directeur ça ça gère effectivement si
les seuils ne sont pas atteints
aujourd'hui on n'ouvre pas l'activité
vous avez bon espoir d'avoir quand même
plein d'inscriptions que c'est un
événement important pour vous la semaine
prochaine pour le club d'oenologie il me
semble bah ouais meilleurs clubs de
france l'année dernière en remportant la
coupe de france des clubs d'oenologie
belle va falloir défendre le titre à
défendre cette coupe et on s'est préparé
pendant un an on part à 10 à montpellier
on vient surtout les grands clubs
français seront là et puis mais ça va
être assez difficile mais on a espoir
il a écouté on vous souhaite bonne
chance et on reviendra certainement sur
votre victoire je l'espère merci
beaucoup parce qu'elle a sur notre
plateau pour en parler je rappelle que
ce week-end les villes de magny les
hameaux et de guyancourt font également
leur forum
enfin comme chaque jeudi dans le journal
le point sur les rendez vous sportifs du
week-end aujourd'hui c'est avec richy
bonsoir florane en ce deuxième week-end
de septembre ce n'est pas vraiment
l'heure de la reprise pour les clubs
locaux il faudra attendre encore une
petite semaine et au moins deux rendez
vous à noter dans le département en golf
la finale de la french cup c'est la
compétition officielle qui est destiné
aux joueurs amateurs ce sera dimanche à
villennes-sur-seine à partir de 9h du
matin et puis plus proche de nous à
l'île des loisirs à saint quentin en
yvelines sixième édition de son thé vous
sports bonsoir dans son couteau sans
être le responsable événementiel à l'île
des loisirs justement sentez vous sport
alors c'est un événement national
c'est pas propre à l'île des loisirs
l'objectif c'est d'expliquer les
bienfaits du sport sur l'organisme c'est
très louable
quel est le public visé alors
effectivement c'est un événement
national et même européen maintenant
puisque
l'europe ça sonnera dans les os donc
européenne week of sportski donc
aujourd'hui exactement
donc concrètement c'est vraiment destiné
à tous à tous aussi bien public familial
les les grands les petits à partir de 6
ans les ados etc
ça a vraiment pour objectif d'amener les
les franciliens les saint quentinois
plus précisément en pratiquer une
activité sportive régulière et à la
pratique et de bonnes façons puisque là
on voit aujourd'hui qu'il ya un grand
développement de la pratique autonome
mais pas faire exactement il ya des
échauffements il ya une nutrition adapté
donc c'est vraiment amener ce biais là
c'est à dire la pratique sportive mais
aussi le pôle santé aussi bien se lancer
sur le réseau santé de son territoire
mais bien évidemment ça vous l'avais dit
il ya un engouement d'oncle en termes de
visiteurs ça se retrouve plus de 3000
visiteurs sur les précédentes
participations
l'île des loisirs qui sera divisé en
plusieurs espaces on va voir là la carte
de l'île des loisirs juste après le
centre équestre des stands judogi
badminton ce sont les clubs locaux qui
vont venir participer ou alors ce sont
d'autres animateurs des sociétés privées
qui anime tout ça alors on s'appuie sur
des partenaires comme la mgen où le
conseil régional d'île de france qui lui
permet de financer l'activité
ensuite c'est les comités départementaux
le ligues régionales sportives qui elles
font appel à leurs éducateurs soient des
comités soit des clubs locaux et donc
cesser ligue et ses comités qui viennent
qui viennent animer chacun de ses
activités cédées comité ou des ligues
qui on est en partenariat toute l'année
et qui sont vraiment investis sur l'île
de loisirs pour proposer à tous une
découverte de leur sport donc on viendra
pas forcément pour s'inscrire dans une
association c'est pas le but de ce
week-end non le but de ce week-end c'est
vraiment c'est montrer que c'est facile
de se mettre à une activité sportive que
ce soit un sport de combat comme du judo
que ce soit du tir à la sarbacane du
golfe pourquoi pas en aussi à bloquer
une qui participe avec nous ses côtés de
lee de loisirs fort sur même le site de
l'île de loisirs donc le sport mais avec
des précautions bien
au mans il y aura des ostéopathes
présent pour ceux qui se blesseront sait
jamais exactement alors un café on va
essayer de prévenir les blessures avec
les animaux pattes mais il ya tout un
pôle santé avec lee ps donc l'institut
pour la promotion de la santé
les ostéopathes effectivement elm donc
est ce qu a pas de liberté mobilité qui
travaille vraiment sur la notion de
handicap et donc il faudrait que c'est
vraiment un week end pour tous puisque
on a fusionné deux projets oui les
mixités aujourd'hui avec les personnes
en situation de handicap et tous ces
projets sportifs
il y avait deux événements qui ont
fusionné il ya deux ans dans tout à fait
on avait un événement qui avait
d'ampleur qui s'appelait vraie
découverte pour tous mais qui nous
demandait énormément de moyens et
d'investissement se soit matériel ou en
temps humain et donc on a décidé de
fusionner ses projets puisque
aujourd'hui du coup c'est un événement
qui permet à tous de pratiquer aussi
bien des activités accessibles que des
activités
voilà pour tous sentez vous sport à
l'île des loisirs 12 et 13 septembre ce
week end
on n'a plus le temps vraiment de
l'aborder mais le week end après 19 20
septembre pour les journées du
patrimoine y aura des animations que si
à la base de loisirs pour découvrir la
richesse et notamment pour découvrir les
temps parce que c'est le plus grand de
la région qui est abrité sur votre
voiture votre base
et puis la journée nationale autour du
sport équestre avec le centre équestre
qui sera ouvert voilà merci wilfried
alors c'est la fin de cette édition
demain on vous retrouve pour le journal
on me le dit quand à moi je vous
retrouve lundi je vous souhaite donc un
excellent week-end est aussi une très
bonne soirée au revoir